[Music]
[Applause]
hall of famer reggie miller back on the
program
steph curry goes for 43 in game four no
game on sunday game coming up tonight in
san francisco golden state favored by
three and a half who do you like reg
why do i feel like
i'm playing in this game i i i'm just as
nervous in this series uh why look
let me let me tell you this it's because
you
as a former athlete
um
and obviously
having been on turner for the last 15
plus years you get invested in these
teams and certain individuals
and
those sweaty palms start to come back
and now that the series is 2-2
as a player these were always the best
games to play in the swing game five
because right now
whoever wins game five
you are one
game away from immortality right it's
almost like you can taste it but so many
things can go wrong or right
for your particular team and i feel like
i'm
i'm living through the celtics i'm
living through the warriors i'm living
on every shot
you know watching dream mon green
struggle
i feel it
so that's why i'm like so nervous and
i'm not even playing it's fun to watch
i'm glad i'm not participating because i
i couldn't
bear the stress
but it's interesting and fun to watch
being a former player being in
some of their shoes and understanding
what they're going through
okay give me what the celtics philosophy
was supposed to be guarding steph curry
in game four
put him in every
offensive package that they were gonna
do and we've seen this throughout the
playoffs
so
every time marcus smart is going up
because that's who steph is really
guarding this mark is smart
that's why they're always bringing
either jalen brown or tatum up in a
simple one-two screen so they can get
this switch
and curry has to guard one of those two
guys
the problem for the celtics is jason
tatum is not having one of those series
that we saw when he played brooklyn and
kd or milwaukee
and giannis he's struggling brown is
playing great so
to me they're somewhat letting steph off
the hook because jason tatum is not
having one of those series but you want
to put steph in every action you want
him to work at the defensive end to try
to take some of that steam away
from his offense which really hasn't
happened in this series theodore okay
but i don't understand the open looks
that he's getting i i understand you
know he's he's a better dribbler than we
give him credit for he creates
separation but they're doing the same
thing at the other end they get steph in
a pick and roll al horford's on him and
he takes advantage of that but at some
point does boston just say
we're going to double you we're going to
make sure if anybody shoots at draymond
green we'll even leave him open
i can't let steph curry have the ball
even though he's getting contested looks
i just don't understand how we don't
take they don't take the ball out of his
hands well here here's two problems that
the celtics are doing especially on that
high screening roll al horford and more
particular
uh robert williams they're staying so
low
so when he comes off that high screen
and roll and the big is in a drop
that's like you know shoot target
shooting for
stephen curry
to me either trap and get the ball out
of his hands but here's the problem when
you trap steph
because draymond green is so good at
passing the basketball i know he's not
offensively he's been challenged in this
series but now
the warriors have the mismatch so when
you trap them it's three on two on the
back side so it's either a lob to loonie
or it's a spray open three to pool or
wiggins in the corner or a layup for
looney so that's the problem when you
trap him you are opening up a lot more
possibilities and other guys getting
involved as opposed to hoping and
wishing
that curry misses the shot which
you know he's what 50 49 and 86 in this
series he's not doing
where would you rank how would you rank
that performance on friday night by
curry well
no question arguably it's his greatest
playoff performance i think
you look at the great players everyone
has a signature game michael jordan has
quite a few of them but you know people
will always remember the flu game or the
shadow or hilo in cleveland or the shrug
versus portland
uh kobe has a lot shaq
lebron
to me this
is curry's signature moment um
and it's funny because everyone wants to
pile on because he's never want to find
finals mvp
you know two of his three championships
he was playing with
you know a top five player of all time
and kevin durant
um and in my opinion he should have won
that first one i know
eagle dollar got it or his defense but
curry if you look at his numbers because
he was mvp that season
his numbers were better
in the finals than they were during the
regular season so it was a vintage
performance his best postseason
performance and what's scary is now that
he has done that see i
i think is he the mvp no matter what
when this is i would
i i think it's only been done once by
jerry west yeah if i remember right now
i don't think there's anyone
close to him i i think if there's if
you're going to give it to a celtic it
would be jaylen brown but he's had his
challenges in this series the one
constant in this series has been stephen
curry i know there's a lot of games
left to be played but through four games
it's like curry and everyone else like
how we take a tiger in the field back in
the day it's curry and everyone else
because of how he's been playing marcus
smart's defensive player of the year
correct
he is why isn't he guarding steph curry
he is until they come to the switch
they either are switching or they are
dropping
i mean that
is somewhat laughable the defensive
player of the year because you just
think okay go out there and shut them
down
no one can shut anyone down in our
league one-on-one
uh offensive players are too gifted
that's not going to happen obviously you
need help
but
the way they are playing this high
screen
enroll and how about the transition
defense is terrible that's been one of
the celtics main weapons defensively was
getting back in transition and
building out and guarding that
three-point line we have not seen that
if you could have any wing defender
guard steph curry all time
who would give him the most trouble
probably scottie pippen oh
i would go with scotty because if you go
back in those series where he won
twice against utah it was his defense on
uh
john stockton right they were going to
take the point guard this series versus
us in the conference finals phil jackson
said take mark jackson out it's like he
goes to the head of the snake if you can
take him out that's going to disrupt the
rest of their offense i think they would
put scotty
on
on curry
and have that length really disruptive
do you think jordan would be upset that
you picked scotty to guard steph curry
and not him
as much as i love michael jordan
i was giving buckets to michael jordan
he's not no he's a great defender don't
get me wrong i don't want people to be
like hitting me later unbelievable
defender but you've got to be committed
michael's job was great defensively but
he offensively that's where he was going
to do most of his damage he wouldn't be
that committed to taking out and [ __ ]
you see how much curry runs he's not
good that's me
so there was no way he was going to be
able to commit
to doing that running all day that but
but pippin could
he's reggie miller the hall of famer
game five coming up tonight golden state
favored by three and a half
are you going to change your pick
because you were going with the boston
celtics no no i'm still with the celtics
now
it's funny when you live with an almost
nine-year-old who
realizes you know stephen curry the ebb
and flows in our household
have been
like
one day he's up because
you know curry and them tied the series
game three he was sad moping around here
wouldn't clean up his room i'm like
riker what's the deal i i just don't
feel good dad
like what do you mean you don't feel
good
my warriors are down and then curry has
the 43 unbelievable performers we're
back we're back
we're back
so yeah i'm sticking with boston okay i
we'll believe it's going to be a seven
game series
and it's going to be an unbelievable
finish i believe
uh
anthony davis says he hasn't taken a
shot since april what is this
seriously
what's worse saying it or not doing it
saying it
because first of all this is your job
i i am what this is why the lakers are
were in the predicament they were
i'm surprised has lebron come back on
top and said dude what the hell
lebron should be like disappointed in
this
lebron's in the front yard of his house
shooting with his kids right now
but when a season ended for you how long
before you picked up a basketball i
would say
with no basketball
two weeks
two to three weeks then you get into a
gym and just do
spot location shots and lifting weights
that's what you do
maybe for the first month and then you
start to ramp it up as it goes for him
to say he hasn't even looked picked up
done a jump stop
that's amazing
because of all the injuries they had he
missed a lot of games why are you taking
time off
you only played what 45 50 games this
season but i wonder reg there are guys
who don't love basketball they're great
at basketball or very good at basketball
but you have to love
basketball and i don't know anthony
davis
but i would think
just i mean at my age i still love to
just shoot yes
and i don't have to you know perform for
anybody but i still want to go out there
and shoot and make every shot i take
i don't know if anthony davis loves the
grind of getting better
you have an opportunity
because he's already an all-time great
he was on the you know the 75th team
right he's already won a championship
yeah
you have an opportunity to be one of the
greatest players and playing for one of
the greatest franchise and right now
you're in the waning years of the best
player of your generation in lebron
james
to me
if i was in that situation i would be
doing everything i can to extend
lebron's years and to win championships
with a historic franchise like the
lakers it baffles me when i
saw that comment
from him because you know living in los
angeles
we all just think oh god he's going to
the bathroom he's going to twist his
ankle and be out a month that's how we
think out here with anthony davis right
yeah so for him to say i haven't shot or
picked up a basketball after what that
april 5th sons game that's baffling it
really is baffling
shaq is on record as saying that his
lakers with kobe could beat golden state
when durant was there and beat michael
jordan's bulls
it's is that is that expected though i
mean if you're shocked you're supposed
to say that right aren't you supposed to
say that well
let's handicap those teams if i said
well what be objective be objective i
will and what rules are we playing with
the 90s or today's rules
let's let's do the 90s
because
on both of those teams the warriors and
the bulls they would have had zero
answer for young shaq
okay so if he's able to play bully ball
it's not a three-point shooting league
it is going to be very hard to beat that
one-two combination as great as michael
was
i think
the greatest thing he that the bulls did
was not playing houston in those two
championships that the rockets won
because they would have had no answer
from hakeem elijah won they certainly
wouldn't wait you would have picked the
rockets over the bulls in those two and
it
i would have loved to have seen it mad
max versus
michael jordan
i i would have loved to seen it
i can see the headlines coming out of
this interview jordan can't guard me
and
akeem would have beaten the bulls in
those two championships i'm just saying
as much as we love michael jordan i'm
one of them
i was in it i was right in the middle of
it okay but if i had golden state
today's rules with durant and staff and
clay
against shaq and kobe today's rules
and then golden state versus the bulls
today's rules
who do you like
i i my role with the golden state kd
steph draymond and clay
over the lakers in today's rules of
freedom of movement
threes what about the bulls
they had a lot of long guys on the
perimeter to play defense there
they do
i think the bulls would be a better
match up versus golden state because of
those wing players
i would pick
chicago over kd in those guys
it's fascinating
i don't think i would do that
you would go with katie you go
over chicago yes
i'm telling you this freedom of movement
but i'm doing the math here reg i'm
doing the michael jordan's gonna average
45 in that series
okay
who's going to guard him
nobody ever but nobody ever does gonna
get so many wide open looks in threes
because of michael okay and scotty okay
i know is
i got who's guarding kate who's gardener
i've got no
no no no no
i'm putting
ron harper
on curry
i'm putting michael jordan on clay and
i'm putting scotty on kd i'm going with
chicago okay
i'm going with chicago in six it's six
okay
six i'm going with chicago in six
because jordan never played game seven
you know he didn't he didn't need a game
he did it one time
okay
remind us of that eastern conference
final
lost yeah but we took him to the freak
instead of one
jump ball here it is jump ball three
minutes left we are up six
we're up
we win the jump ball and if we score we
go up eight with a little over three
minutes left
rick schmitz 7-4
versus scottie pippen 6-7
who would you think would have the
advantage in that jump ball
rick schmitz
if we win that we go up eight
scotty wins
finds that damn little steve kerr in the
corner they knocked down a three
cut it in half
and we just went in the tank reggie
miller blames rick schmitz
i'm not blaming rick
but you would think a seven foot four
guy
would win that tip but if i
go back to shaq if shaq played today
shaq in his prime but growing up in this
basketball environment
now shaq was never a good shooter
not everybody should shoot threes but if
shaq is coming up in a
three-point
you know crazy
he would have developed a 12 to 15
footer don't you know
no he couldn't even shoot a free throw
i still think he would be dominant okay
but we're going to have these players
that are going to come up right and i i
feel like somebody is going to go we're
going to be
counter to what you do you shoot threes
this guy's going to score because nobody
is is going to be able to guard him
here's the thing
don't you think
the way the game is played is
perhaps we just haven't seen the next
shaq
dominic big man
we could go back to playing like you
know with patrick ewing and inside out
we could
it's not always going to be a
three-point dominated game but who would
be better today
today's rules jordan or shaq
jordan
and today's rules jordan because he
could shoot
yeah but nobody's got who's guard if
everybody's on the perimeter you throw
shaq down there nobody's gonna guard
shaq shaq would get as many points as he
wanted to get
absolutely as as well so would michael
jordan because you couldn't hand check
and hold him yeah
and his first step people keep
forgetting how quick his first step was
and is
well what
could you take jordan now
well since we are creating headlines
[Laughter]
of course you can take it you're
awareness yeah
i'm ready for you you could you could
take jordan now
now
now back then no no
i think i could yes no i don't think i
could i know i know you could i could
now
why couldn't i have been like this
five years ago why couldn't he have been
like he is now
right
damn you
would you give up a pinky
to like on your left hand
i hate pinkies too
i hate pinkies so would i give up two
pinkies for two rings
i think i would
could you out shoot shaq with eight
fingers i think i could
yes i could all you need are two fingers
in your thumb to be able to shoot
with this
this is just your guy
yeah
this is all you're doing anyways yeah
that's all you're doing i would give
them up at all
[Laughter]
uh enjoy the game and i you know i'm not
gonna text you right now i'm gonna text
you i'm gonna be texting you because i
uh the last two games i was in steeple
and by the way
you and the fellas the danettes are huge
in steamboat springs colorado they love
the show wow so they they they heard us
talking oh awesome oh they love you up
there
so i wasn't able to watch the last two
games i will actually get a chance to
watch the game with riker tonight okay
so we will be texting you during the
game that's fine that's fine and uh
playing it that way thank you reg you're
the best theodore that's right
reggie miller
aloysius hall of famer